[Music]
you know Americans have a lot of great
qualities and one of it is is a general
work ethic I think you know we're a
nation of hard workers and that being
said I think sometimes we reach down too
far into our youth and expect them to
produce sooner than there then they
should be able to I think people gain a
tremendous amount of wisdom when they
travel when they wander when they allow
themselves as I did to get lost and
maybe you'll find yourself somewhere or
at least traveling forces you to be
social it you have to get directions you
have to learn where things are you're
attuned to your environment you have to
be more careful about the weather and
where you're lodging is going to be
where you're going to eat how you're
going to get from one place to another
when you're there what is it you want to
see how can you find a place for you to
actually just rest it's it's it's an
experience like no other I love to
travel and I enjoy not knowing where I
am
it's an unusual thing I'd sell it and I
purposefully teach that to my daughter
who's now 24 years old to not be afraid
of not knowing where you are so I'll go
for a drive or go for a walk in a
different city and my wife will sit do
you know where you going you not really
just kind of exploring different places
and as long as you have a sense of the
direction you'll find your way you'll
figure it out and I do that in foreign
countries as well just kind of wander
and meander and trust that you know
you've paid attention to at least the
basic requirement of where where you
have to get back to in order to find
find your way home but I think it is I
think I think we we look down now to 16
year-olds and say where you're gonna go
to college what are you going to do for
the rest of your life and it's like
they're sick they're not fully baked yet
how do they know give them a break just
say look I think after high school take
a year off take two years off join the
Peace Corps travel go figure things out
or just enjoy yourself for the first
time in their lives they're adults and
they don't have to be somewhere they're
not told to be somewhere get used to
that freedom get used to having the the
need to self-govern yourself you know to
be able to employ self-discipline or not
or you realize oh my god I I'm really
slovenly if I'm not told I need to go to
class I don't go I need you might
discover something about yourself I need
order I need that I like that some
people love to be said this is where you
have to be and this is what you need to
do are you that type of person or a you
type of person that that wants more
freedom in your life and I think
exploration travel it provides that in
1976 I had just finished my second year
of college and realized that after an
experience in an elective acting class
that I wasn't going to be the policeman
I thought I was going to be that it was
it was better if I didn't continue on
with two more years of an administration
of justice major because I knew I wasn't
going to become a policeman so I thought
I better just go figure out what it is I
want to do and so I hopped on back of a
motorcycle my brother was in the same
position really two young guys who were
not quite sure what was in store
for them where what Avenue they should
go down so we both hopped on our
motorcycles and we took off we left
California I had about a hundred and
fifty bucks in my pocket or something
and and soon ran low of funds and we had
to get jobs along the way what was great
about it is that we had total freedom we
didn't know exactly where we were going
we didn't know how long we were going to
stay in any given town if it appealed to
us we would stay and explore different
places and historical sites if it didn't
appeal to us we took off again we slept
on golf courses on cemeteries back of
mortuaries schools anywhere we can throw
a sleeping bag a little patch of grass
and that was our home for the night and
you know I was I was 19 20 years old it
was it was fun and you could do that
then and that's that that's the time you
want to do it that's the age you want to
do it and in retrospect I realized that
I took off on this trip which lasted two
full years in an effort to allow myself
to get lost to be lost and to figure out
while I'm gone what it is I I really
should be doing with my life
so I finally determined it was something
all right
I wanted to allow myself to get lost so
that I could be found basically that's
what it was and after two years it was
during that trip that I I had an
epiphany that I really wanted to become
an actor and do everything I could to
put myself in a position to make a
living and be a professional actor for
the rest of my life
[Music]